throughout the pandemic all the actions
that we have taken here in wales
have been designed to protect our nhs
and to save lives and that remains
unchanged today
the facts are stark unless we respond
now to the growing number of people
infected with the virus
the advice we have from our scientific
and medical
experts is that by the 12th of january
the total number of people with
coronavirus in hospital in wales
could rise to 2 200.
and our modeling suggests that unless we
act between 1 000 and 1
700 preventable deaths
could take place over the winter period
on friday the all-wheel seven-day
incidence rate
was 187 cases
per 100 000 people today
that has risen to almost 210
cases per 100 000
we've seen further rises amongst the
under 25 aged group in 17
of the 22 local authority areas in wales
and more worryingly still cases of
coronavirus are beginning to
rise in the over 60 age group
in most parts of wales
this is a virus that thrives on human
contacts
in our homes or when we come together
that is why over the weekend the cabinet
met
to consider the detail of a set of new
targeted restrictions
in the hospitality and leisure sectors
and a new financial package
to support effective businesses
the measures we are taking are based on
what the uk
sage group tells us has worked best
elsewhere
so that is why from 6 p.m on friday
new national measures will be introduced
to provide restrictions for hospitality
and
indoor entertainment attractions pubs
bars restaurants and cafes
will have to close by 6 p.m and will not
be allowed to serve alcohol after six
o'clock
they will be able to provide takeaway
services only
from that same date indoor entertainment
venues including cinemas
bingo halls bowling alley soft play
centers casinos skating rinks and
amusement
arcades will have to close
indoor attractions such as museums
galleries and heritage sites
will also have to close but outdoor
visitor attractions
will be able to remain open
the rest of the national measures we
have in wales will re
remain the same as they are today there
will be no changes to extended
households
how many people can meet in public
outdoors
or indoor places or restrictions on
other businesses now when the english
lockdown ends on wednesday
of this week we will look again at
travel restrictions in and out of wales
and we'll make a further announcement
later
this week and we will formally review
these restrictions
by the 17th of december and then
every three weeks
now i recognize just how hard the
hospitality and visitor sectors have
worked
to comply with the regulations to make
their businesses compliant
and to protect customers from the threat
of coronavirus
i am very grateful for everything the
sector has done
and i know that these new restrictions
will be difficult coming as they do
at one of the busiest times of the year
but it is a simple fact that we continue
to face a virus that is moving
incredibly quickly across wales
and a virus that will exploit every
opportunity
when we spend time with one another
to support the businesses affected by
these new restrictions
we will provide the most generous
package of financial assistance
anywhere in the united kingdom this will
include
180 million pounds of
new help specifically for tourism
leisure and hospitality businesses and
that's in addition
to the various support schemes available
from the uk government
there will also be a package element
of 160 million pounds
for those 60 000 businesses
on the non-domestic rating list here in
wales
businesses including those in retail
tourism hospitality and leisure
and their supply chains which are
materially affected by the restrictions
will receive payments of between three
thousand and
five thousand pounds and discretionary
grants of up to two thousand pounds will
continue
to be available for those even smaller
businesses
that are not on the non-domestic rating
list